Democratic presidential hopeful Kamla
Harris is revealing a new plan for
government-backed healthcare this
morning ahead of this week's democratic
debates fellow 2020 candidate Bernie
Sanders made an international trip
yesterday that make a point about health
care costs and O'Keefe is keeping track
of the candidates plans Edie what's
behind this focus on health care
well Michelle good morning voters tell
us health care remains a top of mind
concerns specifically health care costs
a recent CBS News battleground tracker
survey of early primary States finds
that three and four Democrats say they
must hear a candidates proposal for
lowering health care costs before voting
for them for American citizens how can
that be that in the United States of
America that I am paying so much for
insulin Vermont senator Bernie Sanders
on Sunday crossed the border into Canada
with people seeking cheaper diabetes
medication it's depending on where you
live it'll cost three hundred and fifty
four hundred bucks here in Canada it
will cost thirty five or forty bucks
Sanders is the lead advocate for
Medicare for all a new government backed
health care system it would virtually
eliminate the private health care
industry health care accounts for almost
twenty percent of our GDP it's vitally
important to the American people it's
unaffordable right now several other
presidential contenders support Sanders
his idea or some version of it health
care is a fundamental right
[Applause]
we'll deliver that right with
medicare-for-all if California senator
Kamala Harris has her way Medicare for
all would be implemented over ten years
instead of four years as Sanders wants
it would give private insurers a role in
the system by allowing them to provide a
Medicare plan and she'd pay for the plan
by raising taxes on people making more
than one hundred thousand dollars a year
Sanders his plan would tax virtually
everyone Bernie full honesty is gonna
cost you know it's gonna raise tax in
the middle class well you got to find
thirty to forty trillion dollars
somewhere and how are you gonna do it
former Vice President Joe Biden's plan
preserves and expands Obamacare it would
cost seven hundred fifty billion dollars
over the next decade and would provide a
public option if needed
Biden's plan would allow Americans to
import cheaper drugs from overseas and
be paid for in part by ending the Trump
tax cuts Tony and add we remember that
the u.s. is a unique among its peers and
not capping prescription drug prices
that's one reason why the costs are out
of control I'm curious though with the
debates coming up over the next two days
what are the other issues that are
likely to be at center stage well
certainly health care given that polling
continues to show at the top of mind
concern likely some discussion of what
the president has been saying and doing
in the last few weeks and we should also
anticipate given that it's happening in
Detroit that there might be some
conversation about trade obviously with
the automobile industry focused and
based in Michigan it would be a
top-of-mind concern to voters there all
right ed thanks